[Music]
you are strong
you are important you matter
[Music]
says what happened someone destroyed my
house
carl i think someone took him who would
say call
sue local banker carl buttons
abducted from his home in what appears
to be a violent struggle hey vic
carl's in trouble turn on channel 2 news
is there anything you want to say to the
people
i know you're out there carl i know i'll
see you again
[Music]
oh [ __ ] they kidnapped my brother should
i get my gun
i'll get my gun mrs buttons
usually in a missing person case people
call the police before they call the
media
carl said sweet man why would anyone
take him
this is a photo of me and carl in case
you need it for all the
press can conferences think of someone
who might want to harm your brother
no oh dear no
no people don't fear you i can't trust
you to handle my business
if people don't fear you
oh i shoot you in the face with this gun
that's my vagina you're gonna shoot me
in the vagina no i respect that area
it's not nice to point guns at people
paul isn't the guy who gets kidnapped
he's the guy
runs off on his wife if this whole
kidnapping thing is fake
you need to come clean so if you did
something
i can help you are you afraid what
yes
i am strong not enough you got a body
i am important answer this doll
i am enough don't you think so
i think so too
it's been a weekend of horror in yuba
county a weekend of
chaos and loss can you uh not kill my
vibe
it's a good day don't you think it's a
good day
i've done nothing wrong i just want my
husband back
i swear these white [ __ ] are crazy